like Chipotle because I could get 100
grams of protein each sitting I have two
tortillas which were free each of those
were 400 calories a pop I would get a
bag of chips which was 700 calories and
then I would have a bowl that had double
rice double beans double meat which
would be a paused double so I'd go half
and half chicken and steak because you
get like one and a half each time and
then I'd be like actually you know what
let's make it a double and then they
would put another half and half and when
they do that they usually give you like
a three quarter three quarter so it
ended up being like a triple meat and
then I would have Pico lettuce sour
cream and I did that every day you had a
chicken breast to a meal it's a buck and
so one day I asked her I was like can I
just have all chicken breasts and not
have a meal they were like sure if you
want to and I was like how many can I
have they're like as many as you want I
said can I have six chicken breasts and
they're like okay that's six dollars I
got six chicken breasts and I said how
many sauces can I have they're like
they're free I have as many as you want
I got honey mustard I got barbecue I got
ketchup I got Mayo I mixed all those
together and I was able to eat 100 150
grams of protein in one sitting for
under six bucks as a single guy who had
no money